it's not about the tabloids it's about
you putting in the work practicing every
day they just felt like I was just
waiting and waiting and waiting for
everybody waiting for a producer to work
with me waiting for a songwriter to work
with me as soon as I graduated high
school wanted to take the next step
you know our music reflects my
personality and who I am so if my musics
unorthodox maybe I'm on Orthodox there's
cameras everywhere you go there's one
looking at me right now it's creeping me
out you know these guys know how to go
up on stage with their bed and control
their environment rock the party and we
want to make sure that at the end of the
day we stand by our product everybody
nowadays has an opinion everybody's a
critic well we want to do music is
because that's what brings us joy I was
at the airport and these huge Irish
dudes start pacing around me sounds like
alright it's gonna go down at the
airport here we go he's an American
singer songwriter producer and
choreographer he's received many awards
and nominations including four Grammy
Awards he sold over a hundred million
singles and albums worldwide making him
one of the best-selling recording
artists of all time
he's Bruno Mars and here his top 10
rules for success any young aspiring
musicians out there if music is what you
want to do if music is what you love and
your passion it doesn't take a fragrance
it's not about the tabloids it's about
you putting in the work practicing every
day practicing your vocals practicing
your instrument practicing songwriting
and hopefully one day you write the song
you know the whole world wants to get
down to and I promise you I promise you
one day you're going to have your moment
to shine and you're going to have a lot
of people saying that you can't do it
and you're not good enough but I promise
you if you go out and you sing and you
put your heart and soul into it and you
follow your dream one day you're going
to be sitting next to Ellen DeGeneres
broke records and watch the superball
I started I wanted I wanted to write
song because I don't want no one else to
write a song for me I just thought and I
didn't want to wait for anybody else to
write a song for me I think that's more
the reason I was so frustrated cuz I got
signed at a young age and I just felt
like I was just waiting and waiting and
waiting for everybody waiting for a
producer to work with me waiting for a
songwriter to work with me you know I
play a little bit of guitar play a
little bit of piano so why wouldn't I
want to just do it by myself and after
you moved to LA from Hawaii you got
there and was the reason to leave Hawaii
in the first place I think I needed to
take a shot at the big time I wanted to
make my album and start writing my own
music and I performed in my whole life
in Hawaii waikiki parties and weddings
and shows and anything you could think
of restaurants bars and clubs and you
know I feel like I did a lot in Hawaii
and I wanted to as soon as I graduated
high school wanted to take the next step
and hopefully do it even bigger so you
got that to LA apart with the trusty
astute kids probably mm-hmm um I wasn't
even my suitcase any money absolutely
that I really had ever I had about 600
bucks I saved up seven hundred maybe but
what was the plan then I mean how do you
how did you feel at this special moment
getting there and having no clues about
what's going to happen next
um it was exciting I was I was young my
sister helped me out you know she let me
stay with her for a year and I got
signed to Motown Records that didn't
really work out but I had to learn you
know it's such a it's such a learning
process and a lot of rejection
I think me left don't understand that
that's just a part of the the you know
what it takes to to kind of finally come
up with your own album is that you need
to be rejected over and over
I'm telling you you're not good enough
to kind of break through that that's
what it takes you know before before I
got signed I used to go and play my
songs for record labels and big
executive presidents of labels and that
was always what they told me that my
music is too unorthodox it's too all
over the place
and they don't know how to market that
and to me that was always a hard pill to
swallow because you know our music
reflects my personality and who I am so
if my musics unorthodox maybe I'm on
Orthodox and why should I change who I
am for for business reasons so there's
more of a statement of my mother my
freedom it's awesome I've always wanted
to be an artist you know and you think
in your mind's like alright I'm gonna
make an album then I'm gonna do shows
I'm gonna sleep all day wake up do
another show wake up in another city I'm
finding out that it's not like that yeah
I'll find out you know you got to put in
some hard work and you know for people
to know who you are there's cameras
everywhere you go there's one looking at
me right now it's creeping me out
oh yeah always my it's my life we've
always said alright that's you know it's
all getting used to but I'm living the
dream right now the American Dream the
reason why I like Elvis in the same
reason why I like James Brown Michael
Jackson Prince you know these guys know
how to go up on stage with her band and
control their environment rock the party
no tricks no smoke no mirrors just raw
talent great songs if you have to pick
one
make it real that you admire the most
which which would be who I'm I mozi bro
I think I think um as far as music is
concerned I think no one has done it in
such a big way than than Michael Jackson
you can meet his own music writing just
everything all around the whole the
whole thing if when it comes down to
music videos the way he dressed how
innovative he was I think you can go to
any country in the world and
five-year-old kids will know who Michael
Jackson is because he's such a he's just
such a big part of music his music just
brought the world together bass
clear and after dit elfish behind it
um that's man I never came up with a
list before yeah I mean you know I like
these guys for all different reasons so
it's hard for me to put them and I just
just just pick a few parts in elvish
what what what do you married him yeah
like I said the reason why I like Elvis
so much is because um you know if you if
you know the story will be used to
taking chances and he grew up listening
to music that people weren't allowed to
listen to and I just like the fact that
he didn't care and he did it Bridge
Prince being extremely innovative and
again someone that is such an individual
and a freak of talent you know the guy
plays so many instruments and and plays
instruments you know he can hang with
the best on any instrument on the drums
on guitar on piano and an incredible
incredible songwriter do you have a hero
don't have a hero yeah of course
hmm Superman all we're trying to do
every time we write a song is to just
feel an emotion that we've never felt
before or you know be shocked that why
we did this and if we don't feel that
way then I don't think it it's not
worthy enough to be on the album that
you know we're trying to promote and we
want to make sure that at the end of the
day we stand by our product ahsha's
criticism look the thing the thing is
you know in the beginning it's a little
funky but you got to realize that
everybody nowadays has an opinion
everybody's a critic
hmm and you know you could watch my
video on YouTube and leave a comment you
can go to iTunes and buy my album and
leave a comment you can tweet whatever
you want you know and you're gonna drive
yourself crazy if you really take those
things seriously you know that just
everyone not everyone's going to love
you
it got a little rocky two years ago you
know that's when we were at the bottom
and luckily I found Phillip blonde she
was a tremendous person and a great
songwriter and me and him just clicked
and I found a friend that understands
you know because we we don't take it too
seriously you know we're happy doing
music that's why we want to do music is
because that's what brings us joy so we
were in the studio just riding around
hoping that this is going to pay off
this is gonna pay off I was at the
airport and these huge Irish dudes start
pacing around me
sounds like alright it's gonna go down
at the airport here we go and they go I
I think they're Australian so let me
change the Australian action so I you
grow moss like yes they say could you
sign on for arms busted I was sharp in
I'm signing these like rugby players for
arms and like yo that billionaire song
you are legend legend oh that's so great
oh my god signing page signed any other
body parts nothing in forward to that
yeah you know when you're a kid you like
on one day I'm gonna be signing all
these girls and then nope not me
big brutes awesome are is he ugly play
oh you know I try to be an artist
I moved up to California be an artist so
I'm writing these songs and it all for
me never wanted to be a producer never
thought about writing with other people
for other people so I'm writing a song
for me I got approached by a label that
heard one of these songs they said look
we want this song for another artist we
don't want you know we don't want to
sign you we want to take your song and
give it to another artist and at the
time I was working a cat for the first
time and you know as a songwriter she's
great
you know so many hits and I talked to as
I care look I don't know what to do I
really want to be an artist you know
they want my music this is my music this
is my art she looks at me she says stop
being a [ __ ] she says no one knows who
the hell you are
you have no story sell your freaking
song what is it through a song you're
ever gonna write you [ __ ] yeah and so
you did and I did and that paid my rent
and that got me to stay up here and got
me you know so I owe a lot to Kara
DioGuardi and the writing credits that
you are mounting since then she's dead
right yeah Thank You Kara from calling
me a [ __ ] thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
no-name 11 asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know what your Bruno Mars's
top ten rules had the biggest impact on
you what changes you're going to make as
a result of watching this video really
curious to find out leave in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon